Lauren didn't go to Paris
she's gonna always be known as the girl
who didn't go to Paris you were the girl
who went to Paris I was yeah why don't
we get to see on the show why didn't
they film that I think they had had all
the footage that they needed for that
the season I can't exactly remember why
but like maybe a question mark if it was
gonna come back for another season yeah
I think maybe maybe they didn't want to
invest in it or something I don't know
she regret that decision how was your
summer at the beach with your boyfriend
did that work out for you the end of
season one and I said this the perfect
ending because every girl that makes
this decision she thinks she's in love
and she's gonna spend the rest of her
life with this person and that was a
relatable choice and Adams so upset he
really wanted to try to convince her to
go and she was adamant that she was not
going to pursued an internship in Paris
we tried to convince her but at the end
of the day she wasn't going my plans
were to spend the summer in Malibu with
Jason
but things quickly went from bad to
worse what happened the summer Lauren
didn't go to Paris
we broke up right after noon it was
kitchen honestly we were going through
that was when things started to get
pretty and start to get pretty rough and
we ended up breaking out so she didn't
go to Paris she did not go to Paris it's
not my fault though that's her to see
yeah that was her decision that was her
decision